JOANNA SMITH: Many
Android users have
visual, physical, or age-related
limitations that prevent them
from fully seeing or
using a touch screen
or a hearing loss that makes
it difficult to perceive
audible alerts.
I'm Joanna Smith, and I
want to help you understand
how much you can gain with
three basic accessibility
considerations.
Because a few small
changes to your app
can make it accessible
to the majority of users.
Not all Android users are able
to interact with their devices
in the same ways.
But it is important to
make sure that your app is
usable by everyone.
Your app's accessibility
can affect your number
of installs, the quality
of reviews for your app,
and how long your users
will stick with you.
Android makes it straightforward
for you to create accessible
apps, because it
already gives you
APIs for TextToSpeech, haptic
feedback, gesture navigation,
trackball, and directional
pad navigation.
And there are three
basic checks that you
should make before
releasing any app that
will cover the majority of
accessibility scenarios.
And while there are hundreds
of improvements you could make,
it turns out that
focusing on these three
will take you most of the way.
First, provide content
descriptions for user interface
components that do not
have visible speech This
is especially important
for ImageButton, ImageView,
and CheckBox components,
because these elements often
influence the flow of the app.
So use the
android:contentDescription
layout attribute or the
setContentDescription method
to provide this information
to the device's accessibility
services, so that they can
present it to the user.
And to limit distractions
in your outflow,
set the content description of
decorative graphics to null.
I recommend using
the TalkBack app
to test each component for
logical content descriptions
and to be certain that nothing
in your app surprises you.
Second, make sure that users
can navigate your screen layouts
using hardware-based
or software directional
controls, such as D-pads,
trackballs, keyboards,
and navigation gestures.
You should be
confident that your app
will support all of these.
So be sure to test your app.
There are several
apps out there that
will help you simulate these
hardware controls for you,
such as the Eyes-Free Keyboard,
so that you can be certain
that every critical UI element
is reachable and focusable.
When a user cannot simply tap on
the component they care about,
it becomes clear that the order
of each component is important.
So check your app for
logical transitions
and adjust the focus
order as needed.
You can control the focus
order by setting elements
to focusable or not,
and explicitly stating
which element should
follow along a direction.
Finally, you should
always provide feedback
using more than one mechanism.
Combine audio feedback with a
secondary feedback mechanism
to support users who are
deaf or hard of hearing.
For example, a sound alert
for the arrival of a message
must be accompanied by
a system notification,
haptic feedback if available,
or some other visual cue.
Now as I said earlier,
these three checks
will make your app
mostly accessible.
But if you'd like to dive
deeper into our checklist,
you should check out
the documentation.
There are plenty of
other considerations,
and you can even create your
own custom view controls
and accessibility services.
Now hopefully these changes
will help your app grow.
But if you want to see what
other improvements you can
make, check out the rest of our
Android Development Patterns
content, and consider joining
the G+ community for tips,
tricks, and help.
But most importantly, just
continue to build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
x